fantastic work on the film really love
thank you / - now wait today how much
time did you spend listening to local
radio before you wrote alpha Papa and
what was the weirdest or funniest stuff
that you heard what are you doing um we
the characters part said he was slightly
different when we first started writing
it and I won't name him but there's a
regional BBC DJ who's got a late night
show that largely consists of him just
talking to old women you know wishing
them well after the cops got there
literally that that you know for hours
and hours and people absolutely loved
him or her and so although that was
originally intended to give his
inspiration for the pack character but
we had we got a lot of good alan stuff
from that we also visited radio norwich
was it radio knowledge yeah one of the
locals yeah and I mean when I'm Alan
Partridge was written they just made up
the name radio Maurice because it didn't
exist but subsequent to I'm Alan
Partridge someone named their radio
station radio know it so we thought
we've got to go there and that was
really useful actually because they they
have cards up all over the walls
with a little sort of reminders to the
DJs of how to speak you know and keep it
local keep it local speak one-to-one
with the listener you know they would
have a little sort of time lines around
the walls to sort of remind you that if
your average listener is 45 then you
know there would have been maybe buying
a house in 1989 so you'd like put on a
song from 89 and say remember this when
you were buying your first assets that
really sort of or all of the spontaneity
of Broadcasters taken out so that was
really useful we've got in the film in
Allen's radio studio when the new guys
come in and take over with our news of
American ways they put up loads of these
laminated cards on the wall so much like
we saw in there but then it there's sort
of nonsensical things like Owen the
middle and avoid your opinions and stuff
yeah be relevant great - yeah go touch
the gold
world is on line and in the station he's
working at now he also is a fan of
YouTube and the digital world you see
him in various guises looking in the
film what are your favorite YouTube
videos and which ones provided
inspiration for the film as a few
mentioned in there and what have you
watched recently and what would you
recommend
I really like the you have to help me
out with the deed so because they
goldfish was the guys on the fish oh but
no it's not gold but she's to selling
fish for a pound to think he's got a
little song I think he's at some market
in the East End he's got a little song
that he repeats this about buying a fish
for a pound I can't remember any more
than fishing at least I got one it's
called battle at Kruger KR uge ask and
it is some crocodiles that may have the
diesel slightly longer but some
crocodiles money to snare and antelope
or something and then some Lions get
involved as well so it's like a
three-way battle which two other great
Safari part ones that's wrong which is
does their bit in a drastic park where
they is a t-rex that basically been
chased through the jungle in their Jeep
as yes there's a view Tube clip which is
just like that except is tourists I
think in the Kruger National Park again
being chased by a giraffe and the going
and so the cameras of looking back from
the Jeep and it looks like there's
nothing down the road you starts off and
you like watch the problem this giraffe
just comes around the corner go on
another ban it disappears and it comes
back again it's just this massive
Mescalero is terrifying it's very hard
for birds you have to look angry but
it's very quickly there's another great
one where again it's in a safari park
and there's this antelope being chased
by some Tigers and it just so happens
that is their their bird the chase is
about to cross the road that use of
drive around to see all the animals so
there are some jeeps on the road and the
antelope to avoid the the Tigers it
jumps in the air and it goes through the
open window of the Jeep and just ends up
sailing in the juice just goes drive and
lysis again
okay I've gotta check these out
how much time we do spend like watching
YouTube clips and playing Angry Birds
which also get submitted so compared to
writing you can tell yeah there's a
whenever we sit down with Steve to do a
Ryan session Steve likes to he doesn't
like to go straight into it Colvin likes
to do a lot of you know 20 minutes or so
a small talk before I start but the
small talk is always about BBC four
documentaries or you know air crash
investigation so I don't know if that's
deliberate but it just sort of gets you
into the Partridge mindset and then
before you know it he's just sort of
talking in portraits voices kind of
supports the kind of oddest or most
interesting fact that's kind of springs
to mind if I ask you then that's a good
one oh I can tell you that the new
Prince of Cambridge shares a birthday
with Danny Glover and Bonnie Langford
the fact about that day oh it's 10 years
to the day since suddam Hussein his two
sons were shot dead what a day what a
day a double celebrate I mean people
would have been celebrating that day
anyway outside Buckingham Palace it's a
double celebration yes what do you think
it'd be like being Ellen's assistant
what would you bring to the job Rob's
very organizes but I think that Rob's
got a lot linen him yeah yeah I'm also a
fundamentalist Baptist yeah I'm more of
a Michael so don't know hello my
employment would last I think if you
were to work for Al and you'd have to
accept early on the fact that you would
probably have a pay decrease each and
finally obviously Alan in the film is a
negotiated procedure and he's live
broadcasting from a siege how do you
guys think you'd do in that situation um
I think I would struggle to broadcast
without a siege so I think I'd probably
go to pieces you know that's why I was
the hero and I'm not yeah yeah I think I
would come alive
much as I haven't and listen if you
brought a gun with you thank you very
much
you